说这个话，
可能很多姐妹会觉得龙飞现在是不是有点脱离群众了，
但是这是我的真心话，
孩子不在于说她将来考一个什么样的大学，
在于她是不是在一个相对宽松的、
从容的，
父母感情比较稳定的安全的环境下长大，
因为我老公他是马上明年就可以安置，
他可以选北京，
也可以选现在他的老家或者是我的老家，
我们住在一个四五线的一个小城市，
然后离我家是100km，
离他老家是600km，
他老家安置非常的近，
近，
所以他不准备回去我家那边他也不考虑，
要不就是我们现在居住的这个城市，
要不然就去北京，
我们就非常纠结，
然后想听一下你的意见，
原生家庭怎么样啊？
就是双方父母的经济条件怎么样，
能帮上你们吗？
我还有一个妹妹，
但是我父母可以说不用我们操心，
他们有退休金，
自己完全够排卡的话，
也不会说特别多的，
就是他的父母也基本上就是保证他们自己就差不多了，
我不会再帮我带孩子的，
我们俩是都在上班，
我这个工作呢，
也不是很稳定，
因为我是五年到期后可能就不会再续了，
但是我在这个城市找一个就是交社保，
拿三四千四五千的，
差不多就这样它安置的话，
现在这个三四线小城市的话，
可以一个事业编，
去北京的话也是。
事业编或者是企业编，
如果去北京安置的话，
年薪多少啊，
具体不是很了解，
但是最起码有七八千，
加上公积金什么的话，
应该有十万以上吧，
分房子吗？
不分房，
有户口，
那加起来的话，
你们两口子一年收入大概十五六万是吧，
太不多，
十五六万双方父母又完衬不上，
对只能保住自己和小孩的花销可以不让我们操心吧，
不可能就是说拿出很大一笔钱帮我们解决房的问题，
我们现在是全款房，
全款车，
有一些积蓄啊，
这个拆着房子变现之后，
我们大概有150万啊，
不到200万，
可以拿着这些钱然一起去北京，
实话实话就是你们两口子这点儿收入的话，
在北京刚刚够你们两口子自己吃，
刚刚够这孩子吃饭上学可能刚刚够，
真的刚刚够，
还贷款挺难的，
还房贷也挺难的啊，
如果说你们这200万拿去付了房子了，
每个月还房贷压力也挺大的，
真的挺大的，
就你们现在这个生活在小城市，
有房有车是吧？
两口子加起来年收入十几万，
那日子过的神仙日子，
那像北京的话，
真的不敢生病，
很不敢出任何的幺蛾子，
你们两口子挣这点钱的话，
刚够你们一家三口刚够开销，
就一天吃饭，
水电费，
交通费，
孩子挣点什么学费书本费，
买点衣服，
买点洗发水。
我不骗你们啊，
我直播间有没有在北京养孩子的，
在北京养孩子，
两口子如果月收入加起来就一万二出头的话就刚够，
但是北京户口很难得，
我们又不甘心放弃，
很多人他在北京他们没有户口，
但是我们就上来就可以把小孩的户口给解决了，
但生活是自己的啊，
就是你上北京的话，
大概你通行时间在一个小时左右，
你们两口子的通行间每天在路上就得俩小时，
我们可以先租房嘛，
就是等他的工作稳定了，
然后先租房让小孩落户，
慢慢的学习，
渐进的稳定，
你觉得可行吗？
如果说你为了骗户口，
你把房子一租，
你把户口搞到了之后，
你再有别的主意，
那也不是不可以，
对户口的话，
最起码得七年才能给你户口，
他不是好像已经就是有那个集体户，
到时候直接迁出来就可以，
但是你作为配偶，
孩子作为家属的话，
得多少年哦，
那可以谁迁我不可以，
这样的话就是小孩的教育就会可能好一点，
我们现在三目前市的话，
其实小孩的教育很卷就你也要了解政策啊，
政策这个东西是这样的，
就算你们小孩儿有了北京的户口，
如果你们两口子在北京的生活适应不了，
然后又把小孩带到老家去读书，
那这个麻烦也挺大，
我在北京生活过啊，
我自己的切身感受是在北京生活，
日子想要过得滋润，
要么全款有房，
父母有本事帮忙帮。
全款有房，
或者说贷款不是很多，
一个月就还个两三千的贷款，
完了之后两口子给才那个什么，
像你们这种情况下，
双方家长都帮不上太大的忙，
你们手上总共就是200万，
想在北京过上比较体面的生活的话，
真的挺难的，
我跟你这么讲吧啊，
北京一两百万，
你想在北京买房子的话啊，
大概率下你早高峰你得赶地铁，
你知道北京那种早高峰赶地铁，
就是你人根本不是自己进去的，
你是被后面的人推着就进去了，
你在那个地铁上你站着你都能睡着，
就是那种感觉，
因为周围的人直接都给你挤在那儿啊，
你想坐坐不下去，
我跟你说憋尿，
你恨不得你都得带着纸尿裤，
你在地铁上你上厕所你都出不去，
我没有骗大家啊，
我在北京待过啊，
差不多就你们两口子过的日子的话就是这样，
你说你想在北京，
你说开个车去哪吃个饭吧，
就你俩这点收入啊，
实现不了，
开车实现不了，
因为停车费很贵，
你要么坐公交，
要么挤地铁，
你在北京你就是过那样的日子啊，
那我可以现在买一个很小的房子，
大概就甚至平，
先把他们俩户口落地，
然后安置在我们家，
未来这个户口比如说高考的时候让小孩用一下，
会有优势一点，
你说这样可行吗？
所以我刚刚就问你了，
就是你小孩实际在哪里学很重要，
因为以后就算你的户口在北京是吧，
你小孩实际又不在北京。
上学就这个是将来高考的话，
他一定能享受北京户口那个优惠吗？
就是在报名的时候，
人家会不会要求说除了你有北京的户口之外，
你的学籍呢？
你在哪读的书呢？
如果小孩户口证或就他不安置在北京的话，
可能就涉及到在这边读书，
如果说他要安在北京的话，
我们就陪你一起过去，
要不你多问问别人，
你再问问别人好不好，
好吧，
有没有什么，
就是就天下的我真心的我说这个话，
可能很多姐妹会觉得龙飞现在是不是有点脱离群众了，
但是这是我的真心话，
孩子不在于说她将来考一个什么样的大学，
在于她是不是在一个相对宽松的、
从容的，
父母感情比较稳定的、
安全的环境下长大，
你跟你老公为了孩子有一个学籍，
为了孩子有一个北京的户口，
如果说每天都是疲于奔命，
每天都是挤地铁，
挤公交，
没有时间陪伴孩子，
没有时间停下来去了解孩子的心理，
像你两口子都得工作，
你回家还得做饭，
还得买菜，
更少有时间精力去陪伴孩子成长，
关注孩子的这个心理健康呀，
各方面的，
你想一想，
我们有的时候是不是有点舍本逐末，
人累了之后就会有怨念，
你知道吗？
你赶公交赶地铁，
你遇到几个那种骚扰的遇到。
几个什么浑身臭汗的，
遇到几个那种不讲理的，
你可能一天就是有怨念，
你有这个怨念，
你回到家你还得做饭，
你还得看孩子作业，
你难免会宣泄在孩子身上。
相反，
生活在小城市，
房子有了，
车子有了，
周末还能带孩子出去植物园啊，
动物园啊，
博物馆啊，
纪念馆啊，
到处走走看看。
我个人觉得孩子他的那种内心的豁达，
心理的健康以及从容感，
并不是轻易能得到的，
它是需要爸爸妈妈花很多的时间去陪伴和浇灌的。
请送你参考，
拜拜啊，
因为我也确实在北京待过啊，
就是在北京牛马一样的生活，
你说动不动一套房500万打底，
动不动一套房600万，
500万都已经算是最平常的房子啊，
最寻常的房子了啊，
你说你一辈子诶，
起早贪黑的赶公交赶地铁，
被老板骂，
被领导训，
就为那个小小的水泥盒子。
北京的教育资源也非常卷呀，
我飞姐以后还会去北京生活吗？
不会不会，
我感觉我以后的生活就是什么云南呀，
三亚呀，
广东这边，
这边的话到处都好多房子都挺便宜的，
气候又温暖，
房子又便宜，
深圳也挺好的，
而且深圳房子还有点贵，
你们家。
薇姐，
现在这个实力还不太允许，
我现在是什么状态呢？
也不是说哭穷，
也不是说装穷，
我现在状态是我挣100块钱，
但是我就花个20块钱，
我就愁瞅啊，
谁能明白我现在这个状态，
我挣100块钱我只花20，
记得点赞赞这。